but she told me when i was in like grade
five that i laughed or maybe like
younger grade three or something that i
laughed like a goat
and then i stopped laughing like when i
i just wanted to see if i could do it
didn't know if i could i have a new
skill
i'm good
you're good you're fine with these
i don't know if this happens to people
but
it must happen to people where you you
don't know how to if you're in joy
you're like what's happening
what is this
holy [ __ ] guys it's a live episode on my
couch in my podcasting room with nicole
arbour
welcome to episode 108. nicole is a
comedian she releases super fancy
sometimes political short videos satire
that often go viral she's a former
cheerleader realistically she's still a
cheerleader she can sing she can dance
she can imitate a goat she's a
multi-talented individual we decided to
do a podcast because she was in toronto
and she makes me laugh and i really
needed some laughs after the last few
months
subscribe
if you enjoy this
[Music]
nicole arbour welcome to my podcast
again hi friend hi sitting on under
couch this is awesome do you like the
couch i love your couch i love the couch
in here and i love all of your couches
thank you that you stole from nonas i
didn't steal i paid them you paid the
nobody else would buy these couches i
love them so much thank you i love them
too an unhealthy amount like really
really i don't want to know what you did
yeah it's not where i was going with
that i went there
oh my gosh i'm so happy to be with you
do your intro i'm gonna screw it up yeah
no no i do the intro afterwards okay
cool we're just starting this is us
we're on
so
so
where are you living now what's your
plan let's start with that okay let's do
that um i do no i'm derailing you okay
i'm just telling you that it is so fun
to be sitting with you
like a girl that is a friend of mine
that i never have to worry about you
having like weird intentions that you're
going to like weirdly edit this or
anything we can just like chill i just
want to say that good i appreciate that
i've had some people come on and they're
like yeah i'm coming on because you
don't edit your podcast
and i did say i like slightly beautify
them like a tiny bit as you should yeah
i don't know why you just like a really
tiny bit it's mostly mostly that but i
feel like you should the answer of your
question um i'm between nashville and
toronto right now and nashville is the
freaking best nashville is amazing
everybody no don't everybody live in
nashville leave it for us yeah yeah i'm
trying to make you live in nashville
yeah yeah so we went out for drinks a
week ago yeah which was a weird
experience that i want to talk about
okay go on yeah but we'll get into that
in a sec but you were saying nashville's
a really nice place to live because i
was saying i wanted to go to austin yeah
because i'm interested in like some of
the people moving there and
the weather and the fact it's a little
bit less restricted yeah you were like
no nashville yeah yeah well austin's
dope but nashville is just freaking
awesome it's the people it's like
the i'm a christian and there's just it
feels like it's been preserved in time
there's christian values and people
say things and then they do it and i
don't feel
like in la there's like malicious people
everywhere trying to claw their way to
the top in nashville it's collaborative
and people just love on each other and
cheer for each other and i'm like this
is my vibe
yeah that's nice like small town kinda
small town but in a city it's like
nashvegas like the i've also never been
to las vegas so
can i take you to las vegas yeah one
hundred percent oh that's so there's the
police are gonna get called something is
gonna happen if you and i go and yeah
it's good we should do it okay let's do
it so i'm into it before we get started
i wanted to say so we went out for
drinks the other week and it was so
weird it was really relaxing it was nice
like we chatted a bunch but every this
is this was weird for me i've never had
this experience before every time i left
and went to the bathroom yeah and came
back there were just men flocking
towards you
like a magnet
you're like no seriously it was like a
being next to
a female magnet it was so weird you
haven't experienced i've never been with
anyone who had the same kind of like
i've experienced it to a degree but that
was strange for me really i was like
watching it being like
this is does this happen normally yeah
this is normal he's like what i like
your impression of me yeah that yeah
does this happen all the time i have
like two different voices i like my low
chilling on the couch voice and then i
have like my hi i'm nicole let's play
that yeah that happened yeah and that
attracts people like crazy
i just talk like that you know that's my
like i talk like that with your dad the
whole interview because i was just like
playing and having fun i watched that
yeah it was fun that was fun but yeah
that was that was interesting and
your reaction to that was even more fun
because you were like who are you people
what are you doing here do you know her
like you were so confused i'm like no
they just came up and they're just new
friends yeah like who the [ __ ] are these
people
we're so opposite it's funny that you're
wearing white and i'm wearing black but
yeah yeah that should be probably
opposite but you did dress me you
dressed i did for anybody watching this
literally mchale addressed me today so i
feel like unless they don't like the
outfit in which case michaela mckilla
yesterday
drinking was fun with you like going out
with you was so fun
i just yeah you're such a i don't know
if people know they probably do from
watching your show but you're just like
a chill [ __ ] good person and you're
just cool and i love talking to you and
it depends who i'm around if i'm around
people who are not entertained by it
my face is just like
i have this
it's like it sinks and i don't have the
energy i can i'll be sitting there being
like uh oh
i'm not smiling i'm like okay smile and
i'll be like
come on
face do it be excited
don't look
i was so surprised at how many drinks
you could handle i came to russia
no i i don't think i've met have i met
anyone who can outdrink me it's [ __ ]
up i've been like that since i was like
too young that i won't say but i was
thinking like it's shocking because
you're talking and i also don't yeah i
thought you'd be like passing out you
should have seen my tolerance when i was
eating carbs
it was insane it was insane there's
something very exciting something's
wrong wrong special whatever you could
enter competitions i think you'd win
okay thank you yeah special i'm gonna go
with that i would pay to see you in like
a drinking competition oh my against
giant dudes because i literally think
i've done that before and i've won
i've done that before and i've won are
there videos of this [ __ ] no but there
are people there were people there or
people we could contact it did happen
okay i believe you we should i kind of
want to do that i was shocked i was like
i'm getting too tipsy to be in public
and you're like let's get four more
around but like no you weren't exactly
my voice yeah well
who are you who are you people who are
you it was good i liked it
okay i have a whole list of questions
people wrote in all the questions they
wrote in all the questions although to
be honest and i can tell these people
that
i i ask the audience questions because i
want to see like what topics they're
interested in just to see kind of where
i should go yeah but i probably take two
or three of those questions usually
there are a lot of weird
responses in there oh like a lot of like
they want to see my feet yeah it's like
feed people uh yeah people yeah so not
giving it to you i don't know where the
camera is not giving it to you
okay let's start with
actually so one of the things you
mentioned when we were out is
a music video yeah
okay so i'm very excited about it why is
that happening what when is it coming
out okay in the next two weeks i'm not
sure when this is coming out but it's
coming out soon and
yeah i'm doing music it should be out if
it's out it will be linked okay sweet
link it up thanks
for doing music i am doing music and you
saw it and you you kind of i'm not sure
if did you hear it could you hear me i
couldn't hear it super clearly but i saw
it you saw it okay what was your initial
reaction
it's like a legit music video it looks
very cool yay thanks uh i directed and
i'm doing music and so many people was
that in nashville
that one yeah i recorded that in
nashville but i started doing music like
four years ago and then the thing that
you hear from a lot of people happened
where producers started fighting with
managers over who owns this and who
whatever and i just went
nope uh there's enough drama i'm not
doing this [ __ ] i've seen it happen to
artists so i just dropped the project
and just kept going on with my other
stuff
and then
yeah i missed those songs i might be
getting them back though
yikes yeah but it wasn't worth the fight
to me i'm like no i don't want this
negative energy on a project i'm about
to release so forget about it and then
i just did this one track in nashville
and i've since done a bunch of tracks
and the first one's coming out with the
video ryan long who we both know who has
been a friend of mine for like 15 years
now he's like the sibling i never wanted
uh
that's how i think of ryan i'm just like
ah you're like my brother that i didn't
want uh
always tells the truth uh he's like
don't do music it'll end your career but
he hasn't seen or heard it so
everyone who's actually seen or heard it
is like
[ __ ]
it'll end your joke i don't think that's
necessarily true i think like even if
first of all i don't think it's going to
go badly but i can see why he would say
like don't do it in case it goes you end
up with like a flop and then you're
forever known as the bad music video
person yeah yeah but doesn't that also
sometimes make people's careers
or does it just destroy their lives i
appreciate his worry yeah like well i'm
not that that's the thing is like i
would like that though that's kind of
sad oh are you sure you don't want to do
no no no i'm good that's not what your
music video looks like no
or the song i know people are going to
be surprised and i've so here's the
thing here's how i knew that it like
it doesn't suck is it was sent to some
people including world star and they
were like whoa oh okay i was like if
anybody's going to roast me on this [ __ ]
yeah yeah send it to those it would be
world i sent it to all the people that i
know would roast me
like the hardest and all of them went
holy [ __ ]
dope and i was like hey
[ __ ] won't say you're coming
yeah it's just it's fun it's different
part of my personality that i've kept
hidden because i'm scared of being
famous
yeah it's true
scared of being famous yeah okay let's
get into that why here we go yeah i want
to talk about the like okay i'm gonna
super comfy let's do this i wish tell me
if i messed up your mic okay and legs
are going to go crazy if i do something
like that i'm just going to stay exactly
this all of these views okay this works
and i'll just like turn and look at you
dope um
fame fame
[ __ ] weird it's weird it's a weird
thing that i've had
i won't say a small taste of because for
most people it's
definitely more than they will ever
experience in their lifetime and
it's weird and it scares me and people
start
treating you differently and like let's
say britney spears like i saw what
happened to britney situation
it's completely [ __ ] it's [ __ ] and
it's [ __ ] because it's the people
around her that she should have been
able to trust that did it to her i bet
it was you know what i think it is go on
i think it's psych meds i think she had
anxiety and they put her on psych meds
and the psych that's made everything
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes a hundred percent but
they put her on those psych meds to make
her go crazy so they can get videos of
her going crazy so they can capture her
money oh no that's like i was that bad
oh yeah i've watched the documentaries i
haven't so two years ago i think there
was an article put out and i had
commented that britney was put on drugs
this is a person on psych drugs oh yeah
and everyone was like shut up you don't
know what you're talking about
that's in the documentary that's exactly
what happened you were right i was right
those are something yeah you can see
that yeah
and but she's around people that she's
supposed to trust and they did that to
her and when there's money involved when
there's whatever
like just with the stuff i've been
through with people just making up [ __ ]
about me that's nasty and disgusting and
just like whatever and just so the
opposite of who i am as a human
it's not fun it's not fun i like i love
the art i love being funny i love making
people happy and cheering for people
that other part sucks it's not cool and
i couldn't imagine being like justin
bieber and being like a teen and going
through that
and that's like i kind of feel like i've
pussied out a little bit in my career
and not gone like full out yet because i
was a little nervous about that part
but
yeah well yeah we talked a little bit
about this um when we went out yeah and
it was that if something happens
then not only do you have to deal with
the problem in your personal life and
freak out about it like on a personal
level
but you have to go okay how is this
going to be interpreted yeah and how do
i get ahead of that yeah and so then you
have to put out a story for people
getting ahead
before you're ready to talk about it
because you're still right in the middle
of some crisis yep it's horrible it's
not fun but you know people would be
like oh wow
oh it's so hard being famous yeah yeah
and you're like okay
everybody has issues because you could i
get it you could also
i mean the argument is well if you don't
want that then just stop do something
else yeah but then there are but then my
spirit will die yeah yeah then i won't
be alive as a person
um
yeah those are some thoughts on fame and
we've discussed this before like i've
had people make up really weird [ __ ]
about me and then
it affects you in a strange way because
when it's not true
even if millions of people
think something about you that's not
true and is nasty
it affects you on the daily because
those people are looking at you thinking
that's who you are as a person and the
strongest person you'd be like it
doesn't affect me it doesn't [ __ ]
matter but it does and it's weird having
other people
tell the world who i am
so all i can really do is what i've
decided is just like keep being me
and it will come out like i just know
people will see who i am and people will
see who the people are that have like
spread nasty [ __ ] i feel like that is a
more positive way of looking at it than
i think ah because that like that's what
i would hope yeah is just like ignore
and that's what a lot of people say is
like ignore the haters just keep being
you spread and and people will just know
yeah but people are stupid there's lots
of really stupid people well hence the
comment sections on youtube people only
hear one thing yeah i think like if that
kind of
disaster happens you have to get out
there and say okay
here's my explanation i didn't really
want to do this but here's the story you
guys can make up your own minds but at
least now you have the information yeah
it's a weird thing
it's so weird and like
this is what we talked about the other
night is like i love hanging out with
you because we have the same kind of
problems and it makes me feel more
normal we can both like just kind of
[ __ ] our problems out and we don't look
at each other like an alien [ __ ] i
kind of looked at you a little bit like
an alien why would you do that well
you're you were so i was so grumpy so it
was really nice to go out with you but
you're so like bubbly in a i was just
like is that you like really and you're
like yeah
wow that's so cool
you said that like five times wow like
you're like you're really like this i'm
like yeah
it's like like i said like there's like
my serious tone like i was just doing
this serious tone yeah there's my like
bubbly that's me all the time
i wake up like that
my waist feels tiny
your waist is tiny i know
i'm i'm excited about it yeah you look
good thanks well i had like a bunch of
scar tissue removed okay so can we get
into that a little bit why like what is
this scar tissue we talked about this on
the last podcast car accident should not
watch because the lighting was horrible
accent on [ __ ] i can't believe you let
that go out i'm just kidding
just kidding um
yeah the lighting was disgusting but by
accident yeah so what happened exactly
in like a minute or less yeah uh i was
in bad car accident 2008 spent most of
my 20s disabled and on disability and
had lots and lots of nerve damage and
lots of chronic pain chronic injuries
told i'd never get better got disability
for life turned my whole [ __ ] life
around myself [ __ ] uh lots of
positivity nerve block injections
no gluten no dairy no soy
everything that will keep me from not
being swollen because that was causing a
lot of nerve pain as well nerve pain is
the worst yeah and bad head injury and i
used to shake like i had parkinson's and
i have since gotten a lot better but the
last thing was that i knew there was
scar tissue like like i could feel like
a couple lumps of it like
and that was from the injections
or the accident or what i don't know
when it formed but it i didn't used to
have it and then i did and it didn't
really occur to me
until like a couple of years ago i was
like i can really see that and i can
feel it and it's hard it's not it's not
fat it's not muscle it's like hard and
nice yeah has that happened to you uh
yeah my ankle was filled with scar
tissue and it was like hard and you
could like move it it was just not it
was like lumpy yeah but pokey it was
like spiky in areas but it was like i
had bone spurs and things it was gnarly
gross you're like a skateboarder yeah
skateboard injury for sure with bone
spurs yeah ew yeah anyway i don't have
sorry i seemed like excited about it
i've been like tuning into all the
skateboarding
i love watching skate videos it's so fun
um
yeah but
i do it's like one of the things i just
love watching on instagram like or just
in general and i have like my favorite
skateboarders and
i can't skate at all i just love it it's
so fun
um i cannot imagine watching skate
videos for fun
i watch skate videos i watch
cheerleading videos i watch gymnastics
videos if i'm you if you're in a bad
mood and you put on like the dallas
cowboy cheerleaders show okay
they're just so happy to be there
they're so excited either way they're so
happy and they're so hot
and like you're just like look at them
living their high kicking lives like
it's like
it's really fun honestly if i get sad i
will watch the dallas cowboys
cheerleaders making the team series it's
my favorite my goal is to be honest well
i haven't tried that yet so i can't say
it doesn't work yeah there you go
that's the positive way
i'm infecting you i know it
hopefully i will have my music on the
show one day so back to the surgery yeah
so i went to have it removed and i just
had a feeling that i was supposed to do
it and i found this doctor in new york
that did it for
like doctor in canada was like the scar
is going to be just big you know yeah i
like that i like that like do you want
it longer longer is better yeah longer
and wider don't want it yeah wider it's
going to take it like this
and leave it open yeah i was like
another vagina
no i'm good uh although that could be
handy
that's not there's nothing about that is
handy
fair oh i saw the visual so
i went to a doctor who was like no we
can use these tools that are meant for
lipo and we just have to use a different
tool to go in there and scrape around
basically because it's so they're like
laparoscopically so you don't have scars
or did they stop i don't know what that
word means they like it's like a tiny
hole instead of a yeah
little hole like little holes around me
nice and uh
back to the vagina joke yep
you thought it too uh i didn't think i
didn't think it i'm gonna make you cry
so then they did that and while the
doctor's in there i decided to stay
awake at the last second yeah i was
supposed to be put down yeah no yeah i
want to be awake for this and he's
playing like rock music and dance music
and they're like dancing around the
office operating on me
and they took my starbucks order during
the surgery so that was cool
and then uh he was like
sweating and like because it's hard to
get it and like doing this into me into
my sides and he's like cool we've
already taken out a liter and a half and
i'm like what he's like and there's a
lot more and i'm like
what
i was carrying around a two liter of
pepsi of
[ __ ] scar tissue
and
i could feel the trauma like leaving my
body as he took it out of me i swear
it's like it was like a weird
outer worldly experience yeah i i
believe that i could feel it leaving my
body so i've i've been like trippin
since
it's been wow
that was in may did it take like were
you kind of out of commission for a
while oh yeah yeah lots of compression
garments and like
lots of rehab and
massage two three times a week to make
like lymphatic drainage yeah yeah it was
like some i learned it's similar to lipo
and uh so i thank god because then i
could like
order all the things and like ex uh
kind of see what people do that get lipo
if they had like a big lipo and then
just kind of follow along that yeah yeah
yeah but it wasn't lovely but i feel
lighter and i feel
happier and i don't know i wake up and
i'm like i feel like me again pain is
way less
yeah well fixing things like
there's also my experience anyway with
being injured and having surgeries is if
something's a little bit off in your
body even if you don't really experience
pain sometimes
when whatever that is is fixed it's like
pain goes away yeah like i had when i
had i still kind of have issues with my
ankle when i had like major issues from
your skateboarding days yeah yeah when i
was a pro skateboarder i'm spreading
that rumor okay go that would be so much
better i used to go through the airport
and i'd beep they actually changed the
machines so they don't pick up on hip
replacements anymore unless they're
super old yeah but i beeped from the age
of 17 every time i went through and
every time i went through they're like
take your keys out and i'd be like it's
a hip replacement they'd be like take
your keys out and i'd be like it's a hip
replacement and they'd be like whoa
why do you have a hip replacement and
when i was taking nature yeah i was just
like i'm i don't want a [ __ ] hip
replacement i don't want to be patted
down i don't want to be like whoa you
have arthritis why do you have arthritis
you're so young yeah i was just like
yeah it's shrapnel like i was in a war
so it was just like every time i went
through as a different story like i got
bit by a shark they're like whoa
yeah it was [ __ ] that's really fun
that you kept changing the story i do
that with my friend danelle about her
what she does for a living every time
we're together and people come and meet
us i just lie about what she does and
then i just go with the lie especially
for on vacation i told people that she's
a wood whittler
and there was
is she okay with this she's like nicole
please not this time she just like
laughs now because like there was this
giant
whale life-size whale made out of wood
where we were staying in
mexico and i was like yeah she made that
she's like a world champion wood
whittler
guys you have to say whittle yeah
acquittal get the wind with the whip oh
my god oh it's so cringy and uh she was
just dying she's like
and throughout the week they kept coming
up they're like oh she whittles wood and
she's like she's like
like a world-renowned business coach
who's like featured in forbes all the
time like yeah
she she's not not a wood whittler but it
was funny that sounds like a relaxing
job though i bet they live a long time
wood whittling yeah hmm
don't you think i just imagine people in
jail like making shivs is that what
they're called
a shiv i think they're called a shiv
yeah
there's some shivers or something oh i
believe so so yeah i had a surgery and i
feel a lot better what yeah yeah okay
that's really nice and lighter
that's good
i'm happy for you
i've got i sent you these questions
before you came over some of them were
like i don't know where i came up with
them i just i looked like nothing yeah
okay okay good um one of them do you
talk to yourself when you're alone
out loud not really in my head
constantly
okay like and i'll like coach myself at
a shitty moment
i'll be like come on arbor i always talk
to myself
out loud you usually keep that in your
head
usually in my head unless that's like an
affirmation when i do affirmations i got
this
sometimes
like a lot of them i write and then i
put them everywhere that i can see them
they're on my fridge they're in my
notebooks or in my phone like even
this is like a religious one but even my
phone is the lord will fight for you all
you have to do is keep still and i love
that it's excellent what does that mean
keep still like be patient i don't have
to fight every little fight ah
god will sort it out
like me
be me go do my thing
you stay still nicole i got you that's
kind of how i feel about it i feel like
god's kind of my bodyguard a little
we had chats about this we did yeah
we did i'm not quite there yet i know
i'm almost there i'm just like i don't
know
i i don't know i know you don't know but
i feel like it's okay to not go badly
unless i'm actively trying to stop them
from going badly all the time nah prayer
yeah yeah yeah
just i know lots of people do it and
they say it works the last it's kind of
it's like placing an order and then yeah
it's just like for me especially the
last year last two years i just feel
happier when i'm
going to church and listening to sermons
and being around people who actually
live that and are
what they say they are and forgiveness
is dope like that's that's so taught
especially in christianity like grace
and forgiveness i think those are
[ __ ] awesome and
i think it's like a level of empathy and
it's eq to me like if you want to break
it down that way but i just think with
canceled culture going rampant
it's kind of awesome to be like
people screw up it's okay
like i think that's really important
it is important yeah yeah people are
pretty angry
and we all suck we all suck sometimes
yeah everybody sucks and makes mistakes
especially with everybody on social
media too it's like how are you supposed
to put yourself out there and not make a
mistake ever be perfect all the time
this is a lesson we should teach our
teens for sure
yeah oh my god can you ima i am so
i'm so glad i didn't have to deal with
social media when i was 14
or 13 because like putting out tick
tocks or something of something that i
thought was cool yeah and was just
really i can't imagine i don't know how
people do it at the moment i think of
college i think of all the dumb [ __ ] i
did in college and if that was
videotaped i would never be employed
like
i can't like i don't even want to say
all the dumb [ __ ] i've done
but it's dumb it's really stupid or
imagine like your friends or you're out
somewhere and like you're falling down
drunk and they're taping it and they put
it online and then you see it on one of
these massive pages and then like
barstool sports reposted on chicks and
you're like [ __ ]
i was just [ __ ] you bar stool sports
yeah like i'm 20. yeah i'm 20. this is
what i'm supposed to do i broke up with
my boyfriend i got [ __ ] faced i fell
down my skirt's over my head like
[ __ ] let me live you know
and then
it's viral and then they google you for
your new job and they see your payment
when you're like 40. yeah like what
happened here and you're like well i
don't remember i broke up with my
boyfriend kind of sucked
had a lot to drink had fun
panties legs overhead yeah is what it is
yeah well if you got hired somewhere
cool they'd probably be like yeah 20. no
if you're on only fans it made you more
money that's what do you think
what are your thoughts on only fans it
was different pre-pandemic and then mid
and post-pandemic
i think we are post-pandemic now i don't
care what the president says
um yeah i'd say this is pretty close to
post-pandemic yeah well we're trying to
hold on to power change the rules every
day it's like okay
um
buddy we're on to you we're on to you
now like
you know we're done everyone is bored
everybody yeah people who are like no we
should stay home even those people are
bored those people are like yeah brah
nah like when you went from get the
vaccine you don't have to wear a mask to
get the vaccine but also wear a mask and
you also might get covered still it's
like
now you're just [ __ ] with us bite in
like it's pretty obvious you don't know
what the [ __ ] is happening i'm swearing
a lot i'm sorry that's okay i think you
can do that on this podcast yes it's my
partner you asked the owner okay sweet
yeah um
only fans yeah
i used to be like i don't like this i
don't like this for women i'm talking
about the the nudies on the only fans
there's other artists on there too yeah
let's go with the nudies the noodies
that's the majority of it isn't it oh
yeah yeah i used to freaking
hate that well i still like i don't want
women doing sex work i don't like
they can do whatever they want i'm gonna
love them i'm gonna cheer for you i want
you to be happy have an awesome life
no little girl is like you know what i
want to do when i'm older i want to take
random dicks
on film and
whatever like i know that there's a lot
of trauma
and a lot of abuse attached to the porn
industry and i i was like this is just
spilling over
however
when so many people lost their jobs
and they had nothing else to do i was
like i get it
like i literally just like snap i was
like okay i get it i'm not gonna be like
condemning people for paying their bills
if a girl's showing her boobs in her
butt online and that's how she's
eating food or feeding her family even
like it's not ideal but who the [ __ ] am
i to say don't do it you know like
i don't want to do it i don't want
people i love to be doing it but
if that's what makes you feel awesome
right now and it's helping you pay for
your life then all right
i just kind of feel like the world
everybody gets a pass to do whatever
they have to do for the next bit to get
back to normal
yeah how about you what are your
thoughts
i've been like kind of torn about it and
i think initially i was like it makes it
too easy like when i was in college i
had friends that were like okay i need a
sugar daddy find a sugar daddy yeah yeah
one one dude
you go out for dinner maybe you sleep
with them depends on the arrangement
they give you money you have no money
yeah just like sugar daddy yep but
there's like it's kind of hard it's kind
of hard to get it's not hard to get a
sugar daddy but it's kind of hard to get
a sugar it's kind of hard there's effort
yeah there's effort yeah and then
there's effort required and it's also
kind of scary because you're going to go
meet somebody in person so there's like
a lot of steps to doing that yes that
stop you from doing it yes other than
just the fact that you don't want to
right yeah there's just like steps with
i think every girl considers that at
some point it's just like a [ __ ] work
like you're in a grocery store or
something for a while you're getting
like ten or nine or eight dollars an
hour or working as a waitress all day
yeah i used to love waitressing though
but we talked about this before it's
because i worked at hooters that's a
yeah it was fun
i liked the hooters part of the
conversation yeah
it was good we might have to touch on
that again okay but but only fans like i
think it makes it too easy like i think
if you're
you know an 18 year old or 19 year old
prefrontal cortex hasn't grown in you're
just like while my friends are doing it
everybody says it's okay like stop
telling me what to do yeah yeah i can do
whatever i want this is what i want even
though maybe it's not what you want when
you're 25 26 or maybe it's not what you
want right then yes everyone is like
kind of cool maybe or like how popular
can i get on here yeah type of thing and
so then it makes it really easy to
do that kind of stuff and then maybe you
don't feel so hot about that
later right away or maybe later and so i
think the problem with it is there
aren't enough barriers to that kind of
work
um but then yeah it's hard to once your
booty holds on the internet it's on the
internet period like there's no takesies
backsies you know so you're spreading
cheeks for five bucks a month
10 bucks a month yeah and the majority
of people don't make any money right
yeah
but a lot of girls do you know i know a
girl kindly who's like
she's drop dead gorgeous she's super
intelligent she's super nice she's an
awesome chick and she's the number one
only fans model who doesn't take her
clothes off she doesn't get nude or do
any of the boys i know but not she was a
playboy girl yeah so
she doesn't get naked she'll do like
like this you know the old hand brush oh
that's kind of like
she's classy
stuff yeah like flirty flirty very
flirty and she makes a killing seriously
crushing yeah well i guess if there's a
chair for
nudity like everywhere online yeah then
that's kind of fun i also think
it's kind of ridiculous with like the
young the younger girls right now that
all of i've seen all their booty holes
on their instagram
and they're in bikinis every single
photo and i'm like
yo i get it that attention is like fun
it's an adrenaline rush to like get
those likes and stuff but
you're selling yourself short and if i
could go back in time
i would definitely have done things a
bit differently because the attention
that you're attracting you think you
want it now but it's not attention worth
having it's actually going to take you
to some dark places like the kind of
guys that are going to be attracted to
you doing that
you don't want them around you
yeah
i just wish that more people were saying
that to them instead of everyone being
like you look hot girl yes booty booty
it's like is anybody protecting these
younger [ __ ] anybody anybody gonna be
honest with them no okay you wear your
collar daddy degrade me shirt to the bar
what's gonna happen you know
and i'm proud of her for doing like her
massive spotify deal that's freaking
dope do you think okay let's touch on
that a little bit okay let's do it so
for everybody who doesn't know maybe
give a brief background of a caller
daddy what that is okay caller daddy
podcast yeah plus two chicks no it's one
chick uh
the main father uh
they talk a lot about sex and their sex
capades and
they get into like some different topics
now which is cool like
you know they'll talk about their
therapy sessions or whatever but the the
core of it is sex raunchy sex sex kind
of sex education but mostly like raunchy
dirty sex stories college kind of yeah
yeah totally and
it's fun as smut
you know that's what it is it's like
silly and it's smart and the host is
like such a babe and it's like funny to
see different celebrities come on it
but there's also like uh
they have this one sex expert on there
we'll call it that uh anyway yeah i'm a
sex expert you know like [ __ ] off
just shut up um
where
she was like yeah rape fantasies are
okay and we need to normalize rape
fantasies and i'm like you just told
millions of young girls that it's normal
to want to be raped and you know who's
gonna hear that same thing dudes so it's
gonna get really
hard wishy-washy gray lines everywhere
when these young women are getting raped
and a guy's gonna be like well you told
me you had a rape fantasy
like
i'm serious like and you're wearing a
shirt that says degrade me and you know
you're bending over twerking half naked
and then you're doing that on my dick
and then you're telling me you didn't
want it like i can just see that we're
making the lines
really mushy and really gray and it kind
of scares me for like the younger
generation of girls
i don't know yeah it's kind of not that
i guess it's no wonder people are
confused right because it's like oh no
consent is really really really really
huge like i know i've heard of stories
of people getting like college students
particularly men getting people to sign
waivers before they hook up because i
feel that i don't want this coming back
on me i have people making fun of me
online for getting dudes that wanted to
date me signing ndas and um yeah we
talked about this yeah that is yeah i'm
always doing that that is something i
would never have understood yeah um but
i do understand now yeah because if you
get close to somebody and you tell them
a whole bunch of things that are going
on they're really personal yep
and then they can use that that goes
badly and then they end up online
talking about it yeah you just
solve that with a hey
are you gonna [ __ ] me over no okay cool
hey are you gonna get this out of the
way no okay cool yeah that's sad that's
one of the other shitty things yeah
about and i do not mean
to complain about any level of fame
because i think that the opportunities
that come with it
are incredible and i yeah i love people
yeah and there's a lot of like you meet
a whole bunch of awesome people you like
tons and tons of people you get
opportunities you wouldn't otherwise um
it's hard to say it's like
some parts of it are so cool yeah other
parts are you just get both like you get
so much more positive and you get so
much more negative
but the thing is
and i know this and i'm answering my own
question because i was like scared for
years about it but it's just like what's
the option you know we're all going to
die one day do i want to die having
known i didn't try all the way
no that's that i'm already dead yeah
yeah you know i'm just walking how far
you can go let's ride this ride out
let's frickin do it yeah see what
happens yeah i'm gonna make my movies
i'm gonna put out my music i'm gonna do
all the [ __ ] i wanna do and then we'll
see okay let's
do whatever
yes what did you think about
jeff bezos going into outer space i
thought it was stupid really because
yeah okay i feel like i'm the only
person
on the internet yeah that was like
if you can't make a whole bunch of money
become a billionaire yeah take a rocket
ship to outer space
like maybe that's his sky's the limit
and now everyone's like well why didn't
you give all the money back
it was like i also understand that and
it didn't have to be shaped like a penis
i actually that was my favorite part
that was my who was good and the cowboy
hat yeah i mean i like the cowboy hat
too it's like and the cat
the cackle
yeah he literally is dr evil i liked it
i didn't i liked it when richard branson
did it because he's talked about it for
years like years and years i actually
talked to him about it years ago he's
like i'm going to do it i'm going to go
to space i'm like dub like it was just
like a one-off casual
but was it one-off casual for
no virgin's gonna like have people go to
space like it's gonna be a thing they're
doing really yeah so that's different
from jeff who i i think i don't know
traveling and going he's like i'm going
to space and you can't you peasants you
know like haha i can see all the
starving children from here you know
really jeff come on ah man like
sometimes i hate you and i want to make
jokes about i don't hate i think he just
looked he just looked like a giant nerd
yeah like he's just like he's like ah i
worked really hard i made amazon yeah
i'm there i'm still gonna buy from
amazon i'm gonna i'm gonna do it yeah
i'm gonna keep ordering stuff because it
comes fast amazon.ca finally like caught
up it's usable now yeah i'm gonna make
jokes about jeff and then i am going to
buy from amazon because that's the kind
of person i am
i'm gonna forever have his cackle in my
head oh jeez yeah that's that should be
my ringtone yeah i should just like or
just like play it for people
yeah yeah is that appropriate moments i
think it's good that he went to space if
he was excited about it he looked
excited did you hear his evil cackle
yeah i heard it that was excitement
it looked like a dick he looks like a
dick like literally like as a human i've
been over this like he looks like a
penis uh so it just like matched him and
then
yeah and
i hope he just like goes and makes it
rain on some starting children soon to
even it out you know i bet he does like
he doesn't know what he does he must do
like maybe he does stuff he doesn't tell
anybody his ex-wife does a ton of like
giving out that money but i do think
that there's a point where it's like hey
you don't need any more money you don't
need any more you're cut off you're good
but then you just cap it you're like
maybe if you have what more than a
billion dollars billion i think one
billion one you know one billion more
than a billion everything you make after
that is charity to the world but then
what if you get to decide those people
what if those people are super useful
for society and what they're
what they're interested in is making
more money and as soon as they hit the
billion even though they might have more
to contribute they're like well i'm not
making more money why bother they won't
do that but they might isn't that like
capitalism i don't i don't think elon
musk would i love capitalism i'm a big
capitalism fan but but
now you're just showing off you're just
showing off you know like just get okay
you got a billion dollars you won like
just let's give them a ceremony let's
put a medal on them let's be like you
won capitalism well maybe and then yeah
the rest goes to the world
yeah and capitalism hall of fame maybe
what could happen is they could decide
what to do with their money yeah like
instead of the government being like oh
yeah well
they get to decide they can be like okay
this charity i'll do my research this
charity looks good we can support this
the jeff bezos dick hospital whatever it
might be yeah yeah that could work and
yeah let them do it but i think the
ceremony i like this idea of a ceremony
for billionaires well you won capitalism
and then they get a sash and they get a
medal and then the rest of the money
goes to charity
i think that's a good idea i shall pat
myself yeah that's not a bad idea yeah
the game's over he did it that would
only work in north america though
everywhere else that they were
billionaires would be like no yeah
especially like china yeah yeah that's
what i was thinking i like that some of
our they just laugh they'd be like now
you only have single billionaires over
there yeah they would easier to take
down morons
no it's a good cackle
thank you i have an evil cackle too when
i go to outer space i'm also gonna wear
a cowboy do you want to go to outer
space i don't i have no interest do you
think that's more of a and not to like
classify be people by the sexes or the
genders or anything but do you think
that's more of a man thing because that
really
well
outside it's terrifying
it also seems lonely how long was he up
there did you just go up and down pretty
much it was like a fair ride that cost a
lot of money
oh yeah okay maybe
i don't know
zero interest yeah not really if they
paid me i'd be like nah
like what about ourselves a billion
dollars oh that's silly now
now oh you get your stash
uh my sash i want a sash uh i don't know
i don't want to go to space i just feel
like what a stupid way to die that's how
yeah right that's you know what have you
been skydiving no because i also think
it's a stupid one i really like i really
want to go skydiving okay and i almost
went skydiving then i was thinking about
it was like if i i've got a fake hip and
a fake ankle yeah and landing is
actually difficult especially if you
haven't done it before and i was like if
i land and i break my fake joints people
will just be like yeah yeah skydiving
you just jumped out of a plane you
landed you wanted to play bird for the
day yeah now it's broken and i'd land
and i'd be like yeah that's what i would
have assumed would happen and then
people told me it wouldn't but then it
did so i didn't do it and then it would
it would i think
if i went to space there'd be that
announcement like
and uh sorry we forgot to uh
we forgot to bring the landing gear i'd
be like [ __ ] i knew it
damn
damn all right well buy earth
yeah that would be like yeah
that would suck i'd be like oh look
italy does look like a boot
and then i would just be so mad that
that i actually have a list of ways i
don't want to die because i would just
be mad if it happened so i don't do
those things such as skydiving like i
just be like no that's not that's why i
like i'm not into cocaine it's i've
never been a cocaine girl i'm just like
i don't want to die
like taking a pill or snorting something
because i'd just be like that was stupid
that's accidentally not cocaine oh yeah
or just like it was cut with something
or like i've heard so many stories i've
seen so many people
go bananas after pills or whatever any
kind of pills and i just for me that's
not a way i want a chance dying not
worth it yeah
that's for me good for you i do but i've
also been i think part of it is i was
medicated on so many medications for so
many years yeah i'm so paranoid about
anything i ever take so i'm like
anything i take i've tested oh so i
don't like if someone gives me something
i'm not taking that because
this [ __ ] probably not you yeah
gesture towards me again nobody probably
doesn't know what they're doing yeah and
i've had friends who are sold something
and it's something else and they take it
and they're like oh [ __ ] this is a
different drug that could lead to death
yeah so
i'm like i go like hamilton morris all
my drugs
and so i haven't really had that's
interesting like i like i'm down for
like weed all weed things edibles
mushrooms things that grow somewhere i'm
done for that i would do all of those
things but the chemicals i was just high
for so many years too yeah and the
prescription drugs it's just not fun for
me to be super high
i just i don't enjoy that
that's fair yeah like i spent i also
understand that my brain i just want my
brain to work yeah yeah i know it does
calm down yeah some haters would be like
no your brain doesn't work
comment section shout out what up
like you know what's going on we saw you
ahead of time yeah
oh what's nicole even wearing kayla
dressed me [ __ ] so whatever and
they're gonna be like
talk about this topic oh my god did you
know nicole beat some people up if i did
there would be video footage like i hit
hard i've practiced i've done some
training not doing some [ __ ] beating no
if i beat someone there would be
evidence and you know they'd post it
because it's their only way to get
[ __ ] attention
so let's just be real youtube comment
section that was my rant you can't ask
this you can't not that i you know what
my my audience is pretty good i'm
actually i'm actually surprised they're
pretty good um
you get like they're pretty good but i
think
is that normal i i don't usually read
youtube sections on other people's and
other people's i don't really know what
they're like but i think it depends
it depends it depends whose it is and
whatever like i get the same like i got
awesome comments which is awesome
awesome and i love that and then i get
the same i don't know just having my
voice there sorry sound guy i was like
uh
i just like choked on my words uh and
then i get like the same fake hate
comments over and over but none of them
are like real so that's why it's just
like what are you doing you're
commenting on stuff that was made up i
don't know why you feel powerful doing
this it's like if i was like yeah
whatever michaela used to be a black man
like what
i wish those were my negative comments i
can i'm going to post that on this video
because it has to be a black man pass it
on that's the second rumor i'm spreading
about you
i don't mind that one actually okay good
you just had a reel on facebook
yes censored yes what happened what was
that about i posted a video on facebook
what was it about the vaccine of course
uh you know i've said i'm not gonna talk
about it yeah i didn't know the real was
about the vaccine oh no that's okay not
to you i just mean in general i've told
everybody i'm not making jokes about it
i'm not talking about it i'm just
leaving it alone because i really think
that people should do
whatever they want with this like i do
your thing
i don't care i will do mine you do yours
let's just like not even talk about it
because it's so touchy and it upsets
people in so many ways
and then i just made a funny video about
the rules i literally read them from the
cdc website and i read the ones from may
and then i read a couple of the ones
from now because they contradict
themselves so bad
and it got 20 000 shares in less than an
hour and
and then it was removed it got yanked
and then i guess they don't want the old
cdc
rules being read
well like those are outdated so i was
just making fun of it yeah like i was
just like this is
it's still on instagram i don't know but
i was just like yeah that's weird i know
right it's so disorganized like how do
we expect anyone to run
our lives when it's like oh it's the
same company that owns instagram and
facebook yeah but it's only centered on
one platform yeah can't even censor
properly but it's clearly satire there's
nobody who would watch it and be like oh
she's an authority
maybe would you no people who don't have
a sense of humor right oh
touch touche yeah i have nothing against
mark zuckerberg i think he has a sense
of humor
he probably does too he's doing water
sports yeah with his pasty-ass skin yeah
like he's hilarious and he knows that
wasn't he on one of those what are the
hoverboards yeah yeah yeah that was kind
of awesome i think he's
like secretly awesome and i think this
company grew so big and and was so
stressful can you imagine owning
facebook no
no and then the government coming after
you and yeah i think he probably tries
to do the right thing but he now there's
so many people telling him what the
right thing is and there are other
people running his company yeah there's
probably some underlying that's like oh
no we should do this and then he's in
front of a judge being like uh yep it is
my company so that did happen but [ __ ]
whoops yeah sorry about nicole's video
again
i've had a few things taken down but i
was just like man like when i opened it
and i was like oh 20 000 shares in like
it was like 40 minutes i was like we've
got a runner
and yeah
40 minutes 40 minutes
that's that was faster than your fat
people or my dating videos are you
serious oh yeah that was way faster
so i was like this thing is going to go
bananas how and then how fast did it get
taken down uh within the hour so like
right there yanks and then i reposted it
and i was like okay if this doesn't
actually go against any of the rules it
doesn't make any sense this is clearly
satire i'm not misinforming anybody and
everything i said is true uh but they
pulled it again and i just kind of
laughed i was like you guys are silly
like it lives on tick tock it's living
in other places but it's just like the
censorship or whoever's doing it they're
like oh she said this word take it down
yeah but that's suspect as [ __ ] yeah how
much of that is automated though do you
think they just i don't take stuff down
that i don't think that was automated i
think there's like a an army of karen's
that flag things especially your things
yeah army of karen's for sure and then
they flag it yeah what'd you say
flagging nicole's things oh yeah for
sure and they got me and they're like
[ __ ] this happy blonde person flag how
dare she'd be happy yeah black hair and
then like hello and they're probably
like so mad when they see my instagram
post where i'm like oh well it's down oh
hello
it's still happy yeah i'll make another
one tomorrow it'll do the same thing
yeah but i thought that was interesting
because
you know
there is censor that's just censorship
now you know and it makes me wonder like
what why are you taking that down why
taking down jokes
you know if we can't joke about
something
that we gotta we gotta worry now we
gotta worry because it's not yeah it's
like those emperors back in the day or
even maybe now in like china where
they're like if you make joke about me
you did you know like
it's a little okay that's weird you have
an ego problem you can't take someone
yeah [ __ ] fun at you biden that's
weird bro like yeah you're supposed to
yeah you're supposed to be able to do
that yeah when i see snl like crushing
imitations of like
trump or other people and i'm like okay
that was funny though alex baldwin it
was really it was funny he did crush
that maya rudolph too like she's so good
i think i saw that oh i think maya was
uh kamala okay i'm pretty sure that's
that she whatever they crush those
impressions they're so good but i want
an impression just as lethal of biden i
want the same level of like lethality
yeah and wasn't the trump wasn't that
while he was president yeah hmm yeah i
don't think biden is funny biden is
funny binding is hilarious well trump
was funnier trump i don't know so
entertaining i don't
know but like i think i don't know he's
not he's not like trump was like
actually funny yeah a character yeah he
was a kid he was a serious character
that's why i love following don jr is
he's a he's a he's a character holy [ __ ]
is that guy a character i love it i just
i don't know how anybody from any
political spectrum could not think at
him and not think it's really funny and
entertaining like here's the parameters
of this character take him put him in a
sitcom yeah a movie like you know who
this dude is yeah yeah that's like to me
as funny as team america winning and
skeet shooting at the olympics i'm like
of course
yes that is the character we're stoked
about that i i just thought it was
hilarious like of course we did yeah i
say we i feel american now that's nice i
didn't watch any of the olympics you
should it's fun you get to cheer for
people for no reason other than this is
what the olympics is for i don't watch
things that like make me
have emotions like i'm not positive
emotions i'm not sure i've tried to like
i've unfollowed a lot of political
characters off of social media because
i'm like you're just you make me you're
sad yeah kind of and i don't even care
about the things you're angry about
necessarily yeah i really like you're
really angry does it really matter maybe
but maybe not to me right now maybe
you're not really that angry maybe your
brand is i'm angry at everything every
day yeah yeah that happens a lot have
you noticed i have noticed that there's
like uh there's like a a sect of
political characters and their whole
brand is rar
i just had some yes i just had somebody
on my podcast james smith he's just like
personal trainer yeah oh i love him the
british guy the british yeah love him
big fan yeah yeah he said when he puts
up reels or anything if he starts it off
with like i'm really [ __ ] angry about
it it goes bigger yeah he's like yeah
i'm just using that i was like that's
cheating like that's a lie or something
it's not but like i don't do that
i don't do that but there's
there is like a crew of people that do
hate views and that's their whole
business is like i don't even think they
believe the [ __ ] they say but
it gets them trending on twitter because
people hate them it gets them hate views
and i think most of their followers
actually hate them
and want to see their demise
and i like i've thought about i'm like i
don't want that i don't want that at all
i don't want to [ __ ] with those people i
don't want to be around those people i
think it's like negativity
and i don't have followers that
okay yeah i don't thrive on people
hating me or stuff going viral because
people are mad that just happens
sometimes
yeah yeah yeah
you have a lot of rings on yeah i do
i'm a pirate i think i had nicolas i
feel like you're actually maybe beating
me
maybe not three four five six so eight
mine are gold
ooh yeah i'm more into like the silver
diamonds
oh this one we'll get you one i know she
has a wonder woman i have a diamond
wonder woman for drinks and it's like
don't rob me it was too much yeah you're
next to wonder woman right there see
you weren't lying no and there's another
poster in scarlet's room i love it okay
we'll get you one okay thank you i love
it
how did you feel um after the interview
with my dad
that was fun
i was happy with it like
i was happy with it i was just like yeah
this is exactly what i wanted
i wanted
to create a vessel for someone that i
really love and respect to just be able
to play and be a human for a minute and
not have these freaking cackling
[ __ ] reporters try and gotcha him
every five seconds like that's not a
i don't want to see him like that
anymore i just wanted him to breathe for
a second have fun and have a laugh yeah
i loved it i was like great i shall i
shall play into my silliness let us do
it and then i did
yeah how did you feel about it i liked
it it was nice like i was like you just
set that up like wow how is this going
to go it's like hope dad's prepared for
like nicole arbour because whoa it's
going to be a lot but it was funny it
was nice it was nice to see him smile it
was funny to me like when i was like is
he gonna be uncomfortable like i was
hoping so he doesn't you know he's like
he's difficult to make uncomfortable he
really does does he i don't hmm
that was a lot of different emotions
very quickly yeah they just like
you threw up six emotions yeah i don't
think i don't think he does
uncomfortable
like i think he gets like so stressed a
little bit but i don't think he's like
gets embarrassed and uncomfortable yeah
maybe that's i think maybe is that where
i get that from probably yeah maybe yeah
so yeah i don't think he gets that
that's nice that is nice yeah i don't
usually get that either we have that in
common i think okay we just kind of say
the things and like see what happens
yeah we're just like here right now and
just doing it yeah i get uncomfortable
if people
if your face isn't moving
right oh yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] michaela
move your face [ __ ] i can't if i if if
it's not natural i can't
like it doesn't happen i'm just like i'm
in my head being like move yeah oh wow
yeah
i'm glad your face moves a lot around me
yeah yeah
i think in person interviews are way
more fun than zoom interviews too i
think so too it would have been fun to
do one in person with your dad i'm
hoping in the future we can do another
one and make a steak while we do it
because i think that'd be fun and i have
so many other questions to ask him now
and like
it's just so funny because like you're
my friend and we have this dynamic
friend you're my friend friend yeah
exactly and we have this dynamic and we
go out and we drink and we have a lot of
fun and then i was like talking to your
dad and i felt like i'm like 13 at my
friend's house being like hi michaela's
dad okay i'm going to ask you some
questions
like you know what i mean
that's funny that's why it was funny for
me people were like oh yeah you're
flirting with him you're hitting on him
like no i'm fangirling there's a
difference
sir
sir i like talking about like your dad
was so cute talking about your mom too
i loved it
and your fans like the fans of all
things lobster-esque uh very nice people
i got lots of like nice messages after
that's nice yes about being like it was
nice to see him smile stuff like that
yeah that was like mission accomplished
yeah good job barbara yeah see i talked
to myself ah that was out loud i
actually do talk to myself out loud like
andre actually pointed it out and i was
like no i don't do that and then i've
noticed i actually do do that so yeah do
do that yeah i don't know how many
people do that but
i actually do talk to myself
like the thoughts in my head sometimes i
say them out loud and i didn't notice
until he was like when you're by
yourself yeah oh yeah weird right like
or if i'm having
a conversation i think usually it's when
i'm having a conversation with someone
in my head okay and then sometimes i'll
say it out loud isn't that weird i don't
know if it's weird i don't know if i do
it now i don't know
i would be like to
no i don't think i do yeah i do good for
you
i don't know
should we check that out
no i'm not like no i'm good this is it's
staying okay i don't know if i'm good
but it's staying it's from the
skateboarding base this is probably he's
going to go with that questions yeah
concussions have you had
um two that i know of solid concussions
nice yeah what about you four possibly
five that's a collector
that doesn't seem okay and as soon as
you have one
then you can concuss more easily in the
future so if you get hit with the ball
or which is like yanks your head back
too fast and that can cause a concussion
if you already have yes which is what
happened to me the last time and i got
post-concussive syndrome real bad what
is that that is where the fights just
don't go they just don't leave oh my god
you're you're not healing and it was
nuts like i was stuttering and couldn't
find words forgot my address like it got
it was bad it was really bad and that
was like 2014
and then people would be like oh nicole
why did you take this person to this
person well now you know the answer
okay
damage
wow i had brain damage while i dated a
few people you should i'm going to
get a spect scan i just had somebody on
my podcast daniel amen psychiatrist does
spect scans which are like blood flow
they monitor blood flow to the brain
yeah and a lot of the people he does
these scans on are athletes in like
football
or people with like depression or
something like that but a lot of them
are contact sports athletes yep but i'm
gonna go get a scan i'm interested he
said a lot of people who have mental
illness he thinks anyway that
it's from lack of blood flow yeah or too
much blood flow but like lack of blood
flow caused by concussions even when
you're really little so the first one i
had i fell down the stairs when i was
one and a half like i which is like that
wasn't my fault but anyway like all the
way down
a bunch of wooden stairs i had to go to
the hospital and get stitches it's like
wham that was then and then that must
have been wild for your parents like my
mom little kid that's like concussed
yeah like
like because the kids are already nuts
and yeah not not great not ideal yeah so
that and then when i was 18
i climbed something and fell off and
almost died that was silly was it the
one where you climbed the statue have i
told you about this yeah it was bad like
i did almost die i got three staples i
had a seizure
i just i remember you told my mother was
shocked you told them not to come or you
told them not to worry or something yeah
i called my dad i was like i'm gonna go
to the hospital i fell off something i'm
fine i'm just gonna check it out
i was like we're not drenched in blood
threw up had a seizure on the way to the
hospital i'm not fine my mom got home i
was like where's michaela she's at the
hospital she's fine mom was like
what
at the hospital and dad was like oh yeah
and then she got there and i had a neck
brace on it was my pink tank top was
completely covered in blood
being a pain sorry mom i'm fine it's
like
anyway being a parent is so stressful
that sounds so stressful
like yeah and how you want to like
strangle that person but you can't yeah
i'll also be like ah
oh no you're almost dead but you're not
so it's good but i want to strangle you
yeah that's weird that's so what were
yours or
kara maybe more there might have been
one extra some i can't remember i can't
remember anymore good job
first one i was playing hang in the
castle in like grade three or something
i got to top a snow pile and a boy
pushed me off what a metaphor for women
in business or in entertainment um
yeah so they just like full-on push me
from
we're gonna touch on that afterwards
just like
i'm like i am no longer the king uh and
then i got a concussion and then the
second one was like dancing
i did i was doing some kind of tumbling
like gymnastics or something and then
laying on my head as one does car
accident
car accidents you know when you're
learning you do car crashes yeah yeah so
i had my main one 2008 and then 2014 i
was just getting back to life like going
on a way to a workout class like for the
first time
and we got hit from behind by an
escalade the dude was on his phone
texting
yeah wow in an escalade yeah an [ __ ]
what a what an [ __ ] he left the scene
too and then he ended up coming back me
and my friend both got hurt and
yeah but i was like [ __ ] right away
because the darkness went boom started
rolling in i'm like i know what this is
damn it yeah and that look that one
lasted a long time i had to go is that
concussion clinics and everything
thank god god for the the nhl concussion
clinics they let me go to their doctors
because they knew how much i needed my
brain to function and like to do my work
so
they if you ever get a concussion you
should be getting
um what's called the needles my brain
real quick acupuncture thank you
acupuncture in your neck right away to
help with the butt the blood flow
because it constricts back they don't at
the nhl place yeah you get well they
recommended it and i went to a place but
i had whiplash and they're like so all
these muscles tighten up which
constructs blood flow even more so it's
imperative the first two three days
after concussion especially from
whiplash to be getting acupuncture in
your neck and i think it like saved me
because it's good to know i was getting
major brain damage jesus yeah i didn't
do anything after mine explains my life
now though
like yeah well for concussions
sir no
it made me quicker that was a cool thing
did i ever tell you this did i tell you
my cognitive testing that i got quicker
but did anything else change you changed
your diet are you sure it wasn't bad
like did that coincide at the same time
no
no that was like a little bit different
i got quicker i had to do all the
cognitive tests where exactly did you
get hit on the head back right at the
back
yeah i was like this is some like
movie [ __ ] but
they were like oh your
bad news is yes you have a brain injury
uh good news is you're
testing really really high on all of
these following things and uh they were
like oh you can get into menza i'm like
nah i'm good uh and then
whatever i just like crushed on these
cognitive tests and i think i go faster
now yeah so concussions are good for
cognitive performance
that's the next news article that's out
nicole
says
hit your head to be smarter i talk to
don't don't do that don't do that
because i'm sure i've lacked function in
other ways but i talked to andrew
hueberman about it one time and i was
like yeah i'm pretty sure i went faster
and he was like
did he have sort of did he have that
look do you yeah that was definitely his
logo yeah
but yes nicole
but to be fair i also the first time i
contacted him is like a year and a bit
ago i was like i think i have discovered
something i'm experiencing concussion
symptoms but i haven't hit my head but i
think it's related to digital use
because of the pandemic
and and together we coined the term well
i came up with the term digital
concussion and we ended up registering
it together is that the light what is it
it's like close-up light in your face
it's like there was a few things we did
a video on it but it's like light in
your face it's not
moving so you're not getting that like
movement like with your eyeballs he says
it much more eloquently than i do and he
gave me techniques to get rid of it and
it worked within a couple days like i
was full on concussed but i hadn't hit
myself
can we hear about the techniques yeah i
can give you guys a link to the video
he goes through all of them yeah like
digital concussion is a thing yeah okay
yeah cool
he's going to go to toronto in september
and we're going to do a live podcast on
the couch he'll be sitting over here
fantastic
give him some of this tea it's great i
will yeah some carnivore crisps
they're so good i'm craving them okay go
ahead so you just saw our non-scripted
ad for carnivore crisps
so i hit them up and here's the more
scripted part carnivore crisps are to
die for
that was also not scripted
they're far better than anything else
you're going to get out of a bag
that's chip-like
and nothing in the snack market compares
and competes like carnivore crisps it's
like eating meat tostitos
they're that good most health snacks
come loaded with preservatives and
artificial ingredients carnivore crisps
are just meat salt and water which is
why i can eat them
in droves so do yourself a favor give
yourself a better and healthier snack
carnivore diet or not these are great
like nicole thinks
check out carnivore crisps dot com code
mp
again carnivalcrips.com codemp for 10
off your order also
i should mention
they make dog treats
they're almost indistinguishable
but don't eat these humans but for dogs
they're really good they're again just
meat salt and water which is what dogs
should be eating don't feed your dog's
bad food they make good food try it
carnivorouscrisps.com codemp enjoy the
rest of the episode i forgot what i
wanted to ask hold on
it was next this will be the first
podcast okay
sometimes i edit out laughs okay you
know what my aunt she doesn't watch my
podcast i don't think so it doesn't
matter but she told me when i was in
like grade five that i laughed or maybe
like younger grade three or something
that i laughed like a goat
and then i stopped laughing like when i
i just wanted to see if i could do it
i didn't know if i could i have a new
skill
i'm good
[Laughter]
i don't know if this happens to people
but
it must happen to people where you you
don't know how to if you're really
enjoyed
you're like what's happening
what is this if you're like stressed out
you've been stressed out for a while
yeah and then something like either bad
happens or something funny happens
you're just like i don't know something
stupid happens i'll laugh until i cry
yep
i'm like oh
it's happening again i generally feel
like you don't understand joy and
happiness i've had a really hard life i
know i get that that's why i like
hanging out with you because you look at
me and you're like what is this emotion
it's like hanging out with the grinch
are you naturally like is this an act
nicole you can tell me
no
no you saw me i know when i get more
drinks than me i'm just my the octave of
my voice goes up and i'm just happier
and silly and i just love everybody yeah
yeah i just want to dance
uh okay king of the castle you said like
being uh
as a woman which we touched on a bit
because i was like i don't i think there
are
there are benefits and costs to
everything yeah i think if you're in
business as a woman and you're like you
have really dark hair it's pulled back
really tight you're really scary-looking
yeah people are going to take you more
seriously than if you're like bouncy and
blonde however yes people are more
attracted to the blondes yeah so they
want to [ __ ] choose you if they don't
want to do business yeah
you got to choose but then like more
attracted to you but being attractive is
good yes for everything really
yeah that's where we get it better than
being nice i agree so that but it is a
it's a sword and again it's like when
people are like oh double edged sword
i'm like what's wrong
it doesn't have two edges that's a
stupid sword that seems like a weird
samurai thing
most swords if it's a sword sword has
two edges oh yeah but then the samurai
ones only have one that seems silly um
it does seem silly yeah why wouldn't you
just make both ends sharp it's like the
queen if you've seen that clip of the
queen maybe it moves differently in the
air when it's shaped like this instead
of faster
maybe i saw a clip of the queen trying
to cut a cake with a samurai sword and
she had it upside down and nobody
corrected her because she's the queen
but i would have been the one [ __ ] yo
yo yo yo queen yeah that's what jesters
are for and
for royalty right being like hey you're
doing that wrong no one can kill them
because they're joking yeah they're
joking i wouldn't say [ __ ] i'd be like
yo queen [ __ ] yeah um
but the double-edged sword is it's been
really like and i don't want sympathy
but it's been really hard for me like
be it in comedy be it in business
whatever it is because i am happy and
bubbly and friendly and look like this
in general and i've had to tone down my
look a lot or what do you do when you're
toning down your look t-shirt like if
i'm going to a studio to like record
music or if i'm going to
any kind of thing where i know it's
predominantly dudes i'm probably the
only girl i'm wearing a hoodie and pants
and i do it every time
just to make sure that they're focusing
on what i'm there to do and to be
respectful of their like kind of wives
and girlfriends and stuff i don't want
someone's because it's happened so many
times where someone's wife will look at
me look at a photo not meet me and be
like you're not working with her
is that happening has that happened to
you
uh no i don't think so it's not but i
don't talk to you i don't think i work
with people
okay fair like yeah it's happened a lot
like massive opportunities i had and i
worked for my girlfriend
true his wife's my mom so that works out
well for you in this case yeah
good job good job mikayla
yeah but i've had that happen like a lot
or people that you're just trying to do
business with i love that you're
laughing uh
they
they're hitting on you and it gets
freaking weird and then it's like it
goes from oh man you're so funny and
like you're you're so dope you're so
awesome yeah she's a [ __ ] she's not
even funny it's just like it's a switch
if they flirt with you or they try and
hit on you and you don't give it back
then they just
and you're like well [ __ ]
dude what are you doing i was nice to
you and you know i was funny as [ __ ] and
and i am funny because i warmed up that
crap for you [ __ ] and then yeah
so that's why i like the internet for a
little bit it's like i can just stay in
my little bubble yeah i have to deal
with a lot of that but in business i
still do have to deal with these people
okay so what i what we talked about when
i went out is i said i've just given
given up doing the negotiating part and
not that that's not true entirely like
if i get really if something isn't going
well yeah i'll get so irritated to a
point where i think i'll be so
straightforward that people are like
okay we'll take her seriously i think
you can do that i would i can i can
definitely do that yeah so i do get to
that point but even
like it's tricky so say i don't do as
much work on my dad's side but when i
was negotiating on his behalf
which actually did go fairly well but
still it was like
it was like oh i'm talking to you know
this jordan peterson's daughter okay so
then there's that so yeah there's that
and then it's like okay i'm young so
then there's that like oh blonde that
plays against my favorite too
um and i noticed so then andre started
doing the business negotiations and it
was like he could say it would take him
like four minutes he'd just say
something they'd be like yeah okay like
i would have had to argue with them for
a month
so that's annoying like that's not fair
but then i was like well maybe instead
of being annoyed about that you just
have to figure out ways around it like
hire someone that's going to be taken
more seriously than you and then tell
them what to say yeah that's easier than
having the month-long battle that's what
i've been doing yeah and
i i got i got sick of managing my
managers though i feel um i've
transitioned teams and i feel like i
have a pretty solid team right now uh
but
i had to manage so many people like i
had to be telling everybody what to say
and i'm like wait why am i paying
everybody if you have to do it i'm
coming up with the concepts i'm doing
the work i'm yeah and i'm telling you
what to say yeah
but
double edged sword i do appreciate you
know i love beauty and i love women and
i love uh
looking like i could maybe be on the
dallas cowboys cheerleaders if i wanted
to and i worked on my high kicks a bit
more i could do it uh i like i'm i'm
quite confident i could do it like
i love being a woman and i love being
girly so i don't want to give up that
side of me and just sit into my
masculine all the time yeah so that i
could roll with the boys because i'm not
a boy and i don't want to be a boy
that's my thoughts yeah
you're most certainly not a boy i'm not
a boy
it's so funny that your interpretation
of going out with me is that you walk
away and it's like
it was crazy it happened like well i
went to the washroom like three times
pee a lot yeah i do not pee a lot you
peed more than me i don't know that i
didn't keep track i didn't keep it
excuse me but anyway every time i came
back yeah it was like a group of people
okay so so two questions one
top stress
hacks things you do to calm down or make
yourself feel better
dance i did a 30 day dance challenge
and
every single day
i forced myself to dance
and i put it on my i started
and i had other people do it with me
like tons of fans did it with me it was
dope teammates fans whatever i like team
better um
it's like calling people your fan feels
kind of rude
you know whatever yeah yeah i don't like
that um but tons of people did it with
me and day one day two i was like that's
kind of silly day three i was like i
gotta do this [ __ ] again okay why did i
tell people i'd do this for what 30 days
30 days i'm like day five and i was like
my life is changing
day eight i'm like
i'm a different person
i'm a different person i'm like in my
body again i'm happier
like it was like direct
depression beater mood defeater
every single time so if i'm ever like
really upset or in a bad mood
i will dance and then you literally
physically shake it off like taylor
swift styles and it it leaves it's gone
and then you're like okay i can at least
focus now i've shaken off that like
yeah yeah that makes sense i do that and
sermons those are my two favorites
yeah and blowouts
yeah and bloods
okay i mean i do saunas okay you can't
like no matter what if you heat yourself
up so much that you're sweating a whole
bunch like yeah your state of mind is
going to change do you bring a bit of
lavender in with you ever
no or a little bit liang liang
what is that it's ylang ylang but it's
just fun to mispronounce uh it's it's
like another oil
it's such a silly word i love that
someone looked at something and was like
you know what this is
like they named it that like so stupid
someone sent me a meal
meme the other day and it was like
whoever named frog knew whoever named
frogs knew
that is a frog that's a frog that makes
that one make sense but like a plant
called ylang ylang yeah that's rude
that's silly that's a silly person um
yeah but if you go in your sauna and you
just like
i have like these tiny little bowls when
i do it i'll just bring in like one or
two drops of lavender oil with me and
just you just put it in your sauna just
leave it there i could do eucalyptus
that's so nice too i would choose yeah
lavender before bed eucalyptus anytime
huh yeah
okay taught you a thing okay you're
welcome i haven't gotten as far as into
essential oils yet oh i'll bring you
some
okay last question okay this will be a
good clip okay oh
um when you're looking for
someone to date yes
what qualities do you look for in a man
um do you have a list or something that
people need to like check off in order
to date them integrity is number one but
how do you judge that you have to know
them first so like yeah sure someone
could be cute but if they don't have
integrity if they don't do what they say
they're gonna do if they don't treat
other people well
i don't care i don't care how much money
you make i don't care how cool you are
like if you're not a dope human i don't
care i'm not interested and
it's like a lesson i had to learn
along the way but that's what matters to
me now and creative is just huge to me
sense of humor because i'm ridiculous
and you have to appreciate it or this
won't work
yeah you don't want you do something
funny and they're just like what are you
doing yeah like wilt a little bit inside
oh yeah and they have to have like
dude energy like they don't have to be
like super jacked up alpha but they have
to have male energy so that i can be
around them and just be a girl and
then i can like go back out into the
world and like you know put on whatever
i have to put on and then come back to
them and just be like have you gone out
with people
that
like make you not be a girl
yeah like
more feminine than you somehow no
yeah like people that they make me not
be a girl yeah yes like if they're
if i feel like they're constantly like
challenging me or something like there's
those douches out there that they think
it's fun to like
concentrate like oh you think you're so
whatever oh and they think that that's
flirting it's not it's called negging or
they like insult you and they
whatever because they think if
she's some big sparkly thing or at least
that's how i see her i gotta take her
down a couple notches
then she'll be mine oh you know like
break her down that whole thing
yeah i'm not into that that's not fun no
no it's not cool
like
just someone who knows who they are so
that i can be me
yeah okay that makes sense and someone
who's ready for a relationship we were
talking about that the other day
yeah yeah dating people who aren't into
being in a relationship but that doesn't
seem that fun
no no
that doesn't seem like wait what are we
what am i auditioning for
there's no movie okay so i'm just like
tap dancing for fun okay yeah that's not
good at all do you have a timeline like
are you looking for like
is the next relationship are you looking
for marriage you want to settle down
you're out there i don't want it i don't
want to [ __ ] around i don't want to
settle down
well i want to start the adventure
but
yeah the next one that's like that's it
i don't i don't want to be dating a
bajillion people but to be fair i wasn't
ready before like i didn't know
what i wanted i didn't know like what i
wanted for my life or my career or
whatever
and now i'm like okay i'm ready i'm
ready let's do this thing let's have all
the fun let's like build something
amazing together
and
yeah
cool yeah taking applications
is that what we're like screening the
youtube comments no i'm just kidding
apply by youtube comment that would be
that would that'd be really funny
interesting yeah
okay nicole michaela thank you so much
for coming on that was fun yeah thanks
for having me at your house sitting on
the couch drinking your tea eating your
meat
oh
[Music]
you